vamos a profundizar un poco en nuestro
estudio de los distintos tipos de
mercados y entender qué es la
competencia perfecta tal vez tengas una
idea general de lo que significa tal vez
pienses que se trata de algo muy
competitivo es decir que hay muchas
personas que compiten con su negocio o
tal vez hay un montón de compradores y
un montón de vendedores y bueno en
general es cierto pero intentamos hablar
de un contexto económico por aquí y por
lo tanto queremos ser muy precisos con
nuestras definiciones cuando los
economistas hablan de una competencia
perfecta hablan de un estado abstracto
donde tienes muchos compradores y
vendedores ahora esto no se ve tan
abstracto hasta aquí podemos imaginar un
montón de mercados que tienen muchos
compradores y vendedores sin embargo
otra cosa que define una competencia
perfecta desde un punto de vista
económico es que vendan productos o
servicios
chicos bueno tal vez este sea un poco
más difícil porque aún cuando podemos
imaginar un mercado competitivo podemos
imaginar que verdad es exactamente lo
mismo bueno puedes imaginar ciertos
tipos de mercados por ejemplo el mercado
del agua o el mercado de algún tipo de
energía o algún mercado que tengan
productos o servicios casi idénticos
hasta ahora sigue sin ser el resumen de
competencia perfecta pero vamos a
agregar otro aspecto de este tipo de
competencia y es que cada uno de los
agentes es decir los compradores los
vendedores los productores los
consumidores todos tienen información
perfecta
ahora que significa información perfecta
significa que cada participante en el
mercado tanto los compradores como los
vendedores cuando hacen que está
sucediendo en el mercado es decir qué
bienes o servicios se venden a qué
precios y quién le vende a quién así que
esto empieza a ser un poco más abstracto
ya que para tener la información
perfecta real tiene que pasar que todos
en el mercado sepan siempre todo lo que
está sucediendo así que una vez más esta
es una pequeña idea un poco abstracta
que los economistas han definido para
ser un poco más precisos y el último
aspecto del que hablaremos y este es
algo un poco idealizado es decir esto no
existe en el mundo real pero si algo
cercano es la idea de que no existan
barreras de entrada o de salida
como ya hemos mencionado algunos
mercados por ejemplo el mercado de la
agricultura tiene barreras a la entrada
oa la salida de alguna manera solo
tienes que conseguir la tierra tienes
que conseguir semillas y fertilizante
tienes que contratar personas para que
cultiven y cosechen y todo eso hace que
el mercado que imagines tenga barreras
casi cualquier industria o cualquier
mercado tiene barreras pero todo esto es
una noción idealizada que a los
economistas les gusta pensar para
mostrarnos que en el mundo real las
cosas pueden acercarse a una competencia
perfecta o algunos mercados pueden estar
más cerca a una competencia perfecta que
otros mercados pero si estamos en esta
situación vamos a analizar qué es lo que
sucede realmente podemos pensar el
mercado como un todo de cualquiera que
es el producto o servicio
así que grafique mos el precio contra la
cca
ciudad por aquí para el mercado común
todo aquí vamos a tener al precio
y este es el mercado y lo hemos visto
varias veces en nuestro estudios de
economía tenemos una curva de oferta con
pendiente ascendente una vez más esto es
para el mercado entero y tienes una
curva de demanda con pendiente
descendente como ésta
y sabemos cuál será el precio de
equilibrio para la oferta y la demanda
del mercado así que aquí tenemos la
cantidad de equilibrio para el mercado y
este de aquí es el precio de equilibrio
para el mercado ahora cómo afectan las
decisiones de la empresa en competencia
perfecta bueno hagamos un análisis
similar pero en un nivel de empresa es
decir estamos hablando de uno de los
participantes del mercado uno de los
productores o uno de los vendedores en
este eje tenemos al precio para la
empresa o puedes verlo como el ingreso
marginal incluso puedes verlo como el
costo marginal porque vamos a graficar
diferentes curvas por aquí y en el eje
horizontal tenemos de nuevo a la
cantidad pero una vez más es la cantidad
de una empresa que produce
bueno en primer lugar podemos pensar en
el costo marginal para la empresa y lo
hemos visto varias veces que la curva
para el costo marginal de una empresa se
vea algo así a lo largo del tiempo
podría tender hacia arriba donde en
algún punto cada unidad adicional cuesta
más y más producirla tal vez sea más
difícil de obtener recursos o difícil
sea conseguir más trabajadores o lo que
se te ocurra así que esta es la curva
del costo marginal típica para una
empresa y ahora podemos pensar en el
costo total promedio la curva del costo
total promedio se va a ver algo así ya
hemos visto esto varias veces y ahora
cuál es el ingreso marginal para esta
empresa que opera en esta competencia
perfecta bueno cuando se opera en
competencia perfecta sólo tiene que ser
una empresa precio aceptan
por lo que cada unidad que vendan solo
podrá vender a el precio del mercado
para esa unidad así que en una
competencia perfecta la empresa y cada
participante son idénticos en muchas
formas ellos van a obtener ese precio
analízalo no van a querer cobrar de más
por su producto o servicio que el precio
que da el mercado ya que su servicio o
producto es idéntico a los demás y todos
lo saben ya que tienen información
perfecta tampoco tendrán ganas de cobrar
menos puedes ver que son pasivos se
pueden ver cuando se trata del precio
por lo tanto si expandimos este precio
para el mercado
de esta forma entonces este precio que
tenemos aquí va a definir la curva del
ingreso marginal para la empresa así que
pondré una curva sólida justo aquí
tenemos el ingreso marginal para la
empresa por cada unidad que vendamos en
el mercado esta curva nos da el ingreso
que obtenemos de él y puedes verlo como
la curva de demanda para la empresa
además puedes verlo como el ingreso
promedio para la empresa esto es lo
mismo que el precio que la empresa tiene
así que el panorama general cuando
tenemos una competencia perfecta que es
un estado idealizado que no forzosamente
existe en el mundo real pero algunos
mercados pueden aproximarse aquí
las empresas son precio aceptantes ellas
no eligen su precio y por lo tanto es
racional para ellas que produzcan la
cantidad dada por la intersección entre
las curvas de costo marginal y de
ingreso marginal ya que cualquier
cantidad mayor es decir por cada unidad
adicional que produzcan gastarán más
dinero del que obtienen en términos de
ingresos
y toda esta pasividad va un poco en
contra de algunas de nuestras nociones
de competencia feroz cuando pensemos en
una competencia feroz necesitaremos
pensar en participantes que
constantemente intentan vender a menor
precio que los otros y envite los
futuros hablaremos de algunos escenarios
donde esto ocurra y tal vez quieras
pensar si deseas o no que algunos
mercados tengan competencia perfecta
porque no tener barreras a la entrada oa
la salida significa que francamente
cualquiera puede entrar a esta industria
así que por ejemplo tal vez no quieras
competencia perfecta cuando se trata de
alguien que dice ser tu doctor porque
necesitas barreras a la entrada
necesitas un cierto nivel de preparación
necesitas un cierto nivel de experiencia
antes de que alguien ofrezca ese
servicio